boy would I miss a day or a few you
people really want your avatar view log
so yeah here is episode 16 the deserter
um and this is one I would almost put in
the filler category but I think there's
enough that I saw I said okay this is
this is good to know like this was good
information to know um in this one they
go to they start going to this carnival
run by the Fire Nation which come on
guys sound remotely like a good idea but
okay so they they go in this place they
accidentally out themselves and get
chased out honestly you probably could
cut that whole bit and they come across
this guy who says that he knows a
firebender who's not part of the Fire
Nation he reminds me a lot sir of desk
hopper from Apocalypse Now he's a genius
man he's mad genius so they go to visit
this guy and Aang thanks well this is
great he can master firebending and they
come across this person and he does not
want to teach and he doesn't want to
teach him not just because he's a kid
but because he doesn't want to teach
anyone this firebending uh at least not
anyone who doesn't have this incredible
restraint and control over them and even
though Aang is a very likable kid and
has these wonderful attributes he's
still a kid he supposed to be taught a
lot of this stuff and he sees as a big
mistake
the reason being and this is why I think
this episode does is that you a little
better than just a filler episode it's
because he was saying unlike the other
elements this is an element that is
actually designed to destroy in a sense
you know a water really is an earth
really isn't air really is I mean they
can but that's not sort of their only
function fire is pretty much made to
destroy something and you can get stuff
out of it but it's made to destroy and
what's interesting about that is that
suddenly it makes sense how the Fire
Nation came to take over everything and
why they feel they want to take
everything if you have this power that
naturally wants to destroy and consume
it makes sense so I found that very
fascinating that this guy did not want
to teach and you know even though hang
is a nice kid and eventually he gives in
because the inner avatar in Aang comes
out of that I like that scene again you
don't know exactly what he can do and I
love I love the way they do it it's not
like a big explosion or a big boom of
light just the lights go out comes back
on and there he is there's the the older
avatar I thought that was a very nice
way of doing it sort of gives you a
double take - so it's that was very
nicely handled some of this stuff again
and I know Aang's a kid and we don't
know where he was in his training some
of it I do sort of well that again I my
original mindset was that he should know
some of the stuff that this does take
time that this does take patience and
he's willing to do it I will say that
what is interesting is that he keeps the
teacher keeps hanging on this mountain
doing these exercises for like hours if
it was an hour or ten minutes or
something like that and Aang came back
at Bailey come on kid you have to know
better than this but granted hours
plural is a while so I think that's a
little bit more identifiable the more I
think about it what bothered me a little
bit is that I don't like how Aang was
kind of showing off with the fire after
you know he's finally starting to get it
down after he was taught so much just
driven into him don't show off use it
responsibly restrained and stuff like
that you know just immediately he shows
off and then I don't know that gots me a
seem smarter than that and I know he's a
little kid and but the way they're
building this kid up he seemed wiser
than that and again he merely knows his
mistake and he apologizes and
understands if he should not be shown
how to do this or if he should keep away
from the fire because he knows I get
burned or his you know possible most
likely future girlfriend will get burned
and then that's another element is that
she gets her hands burned goes puts her
hands in the water heals herself and the
teachers like you're a healer she's like
yeah but what did she always know this
was this a new development do she find
that out at the time it's done very
vaguely and very quickly and I'm still
not sure like was that sort of seen I
have a blue I think you know water was
part of like you know was a healing art
or whatever so so that was a little
weird that could then explain better but
I like also what came in pretty smart
was that I'm just gonna call in the
Malfoy general because I know the guy
who was one of the Malfoy's plays this
boy he's just always gonna call on that
or maybe I'll get his name I'm give
their the other names but for now he's
an alpha in general he comes in the
teacher has explained that this guy does
not have self-control that's one of the
reasons he became this general for this
evil army and and comes across him they
have this dual and clearly cannot outdo
this guy I mean he has fire coming at
him and Aang is it's not powerful enough
so he has to use his wit and he
remembers what he said that he was a
student and he did not have self-control
so I like that he used his knowledge of
his own self-control and his own anger
in his own frustration to use against
him and ran around the ships and that
can't make him angry and angry or
taunting him saying how bad his powers
are and so forth and what insult he is
he's not even feeling it and make him
matter matter because we get more and
more angry you get more and more stupid
and he burns the ships and they have no
way to get back so that that was nicely
good I like how that all tied together
I wish there could have been a little
bit more time if they if they took out
the carnival they probably could had a
little bit more time to dedicate to that
and some of these things would have
connected a little better but they
connected okay so it is a good episode
and it goes a little bit
the filler because I think it gives a
little background just into the nature
of the fire nation without necessarily
having to spell it out for you I think
this episode even if you don't explain
too much else I'm sure they will go into
more detail but you maybe don't explain
too much else you understand how the
Fire Nation took over just by the nature
of fire and what they are I know if it's
born with or whatever but what they're
growing up with so that's I found that
very fascinating if they do give more
detail great but they have it set and I
thought just by these little hints and
not even saying this is why the Fire
Nation is like this just saying this is
what fire is like I thought that was a
very clever way of actually showing a
lot of human nature in a sense if you
were growing up with this power you
probably be a little bit of a bully too
because there's a lot of power to be
growing up with so yeah it was a good
episode I did enjoy it I do wish other
parts got more focus and and like I say
always the opening could probably just
been cut out but I did enjoy it so good
an episode see you number 17